You can deploy Burp Suite Enterprise Edition either to a single machine or multiple machines.
For a single machine deployment, this means you can run all components on a single physical or
virtual machine, which includes the bundled database. This option is suitable for a trial
or evaluation, but for production deployments we recommend that you connect to an external database
and use a multi-machine deployment. We can see from the diagram that all Burp Suite Enterprise Edition
components have been installed to a single physical or virtual machine. This makes setup and installation
very straightforward, but does limit the number of concurrent scans that we can run.
Alternatively, you can run scans on several different machines and you can use your own
external database for storage. This option lets you scale the number of concurrent scans that you
could potentially run to be indefinitely large and utilize any existing database infrastructure that
you have. We can see from the diagram that the components have been separated out to their own
physical or virtual machines, which gives greater scale and performance. Please note that the Enterprise
Server and Web Server are always deployed to a single machine. For specific details about the system
requirements for both of these options, please refer to the system requirements page. Thank you.